aidez se courir fort mais c'est la
mission de la protection civile qui est
l'intermédiaire avant l'arrivée des
secours
douze personnes sont en formation à
poissy pour intégrer la protection
civile
c'est une formation qui se déroule sur
35 heures avec tous les jours des thèmes
différents qui sont abordés avec des
parties théoriques des parties
techniques ou manipuler différents les
différents matériels et une partie avec
des cas concret qui sont évaluées pour
valider ou non la formation au bout de
la semaine malgré un projet de
reconversion professionnelle pour
devenir infirmière donc c'était une des
choses qui m'a qui m'a motivé c'est de
mettre un premier pied dans le domaine
non pas médical mais de la sécurité du
soutien à la population
ce retraité sapeurs pompiers des
yvelines pendant 40 ans et formateur
pour la protection civile
il souhaite continuer à transmettre ses
connaissances acquises au service de la
population
ces gens quand le psc1 deviennent
équipier secouriste de façon pouvoir
assurer repas des postes fosse à la
protection civile ça veut dire que la
formation qu'est la halle et
certificatif c'est à dire que c'est pas
une obligation que tout le monde soit
reçue à la fin de la semaine
contrairement aux pc voilà lula ces
formations les kurdes et pour tout le
monde passait vraiment des gens qui sont
en équipe qui vont travailler avec les
matériels avec un véhicule
donc il faut les former donc il faut une
validation durant cette formation d'un
coût de 300 euros ils doivent apprendre
pendant une semaine tous les gestes de
secours à appliquer en toutes
circonstances une importance qui pousse
certains à intégrer la protection civile
mais par un événement familial qui a
fait que j'ai dû faire un massage
cardiaque et j'étais pas vraiment forme
et donc nous fait défaut qu'une forme
pour pouvoir le faire si jamais un
événement reçoit rien cinquante
personnes sont actuellement au sein de
la protection civile des yvelines un
nombre de bénévoles qui pourrait
augmenter à poissy les douze personnes
en formation ont leurs résultats
aujourd'hui